Many adults may not know that simply being over 50 puts them at increased risk for shingles. Help prevent shingles in patients over 50 with shingricks. Shingricks is indicated for the prevention of herpes zoster, HZ, or shingles in adults 50 years of age or older. Consult the product monograph at gsk.ca slash shinricks slash PM for contra indications, warnings and precautions, adverse reactions, interactions, dosing and administration information. To request a product monograph or to report an adverse event, please call 1-800-387-7374.
许多成年人可能不知道，仅仅年过五十就会增加罹患带状疱疹的风险。使用 Shingricks 帮助五十岁以上的患者预防带状疱疹。Shingricks 适用于预防五十岁及以上成人的带状疱疹（HZ）。请查阅 gsk.ca 网站上的 shinricks PM 产品说明书，了解禁忌症、警告和注意事项、不良反应、相互作用、剂量和给药信息。如需索取产品说明书或报告不良事件，请致电 1-800-387-7374。
Learn more at thinkshinricks.ca Our episodes deal with serious and often distressing incidents. If you feel at any time you need support, please contact your local crisis center. For suggested phone numbers for confidential support, please see the show notes for this episode on your app or on our website. This episode involves a crime against children. It may not be suitable for all listeners. On May 5 each year, Japan celebrates a national holiday called Children's Day. It's a day for families to gather to honor the children in their lives
请登录 thinkshinricks.ca 了解更多信息。我们的节目涉及严重且通常令人痛心的事件。如果您在任何时候觉得需要支持，请联系当地的危机干预中心。有关保密支持的建议电话号码，请查看您使用的应用程序上或我们网站上的本集节目说明。本集涉及针对儿童的犯罪。可能不适合所有听众。每年 5 月 5 日，日本都会庆祝一个名为“儿童节”的全国假日。这是一个家庭聚会，向生活中的孩子们表达敬意的一天
and to wish them a lifetime of health and happiness. In 1997, in the city of Korbe, located on the southern side of Japan's main island, Honshu, Children's Day had added significance. Two years prior, Korbe experienced a devastating earthquake that killed 4,600 of its people. As the city rebuilt, its residents looked towards the children as a symbol of hope for their future. Dating back thousands of years, Children's Day is buried deep in ancient tradition. Large, colorful carp streamers are hung outside houses of those with children to symbolize strength and success, whilst dolls of famous samurai warriors are proudly displayed indoors.
并祝愿他们一生健康快乐。1997年，在日本本州岛南部的大阪湾城市神户，儿童节具有了更加特殊的意义。两年前，神户经历了一场毁灭性的地震，夺去了 4,600 名居民的生命。随着城市的重建，居民们将孩子们视为未来希望的象征。儿童节拥有数千年的历史，深深植根于古老的传统之中。家有儿女的人家会在屋外悬挂色彩斑斓的大型鲤鱼旗，象征力量和成功，而著名的武士玩偶则自豪地摆放在室内。
Families treat themselves with kashuwamachi, rice cakes filled with sweet bean paste. Some families on Children's Day bathe in a tub sprinkled with iris leaves and roots. It is believed that the iris promotes good health. Not only that, bathing in iris leaves is said to ward off evil spirits. Approximately 540km southwest of Tokyo, Onosaka Bay, the city of Korbe is divided into nine different areas called wards. The Sumo Ward, situated along the coastline of Korbe, is an idyllic spot with a white sandy beach, boardwalks, cafes, and cherry blossom trees visible on the surrounding hillsides. However, even the beautiful scenery could not conceal
家人们会享用柏饼（kashuwamachi），这是一种包着甜豆沙的年糕。在儿童节这天，有些家庭会浸泡在洒有菖蒲叶和根的浴缸中。人们相信菖蒲能促进身体健康。不仅如此，据说用菖蒲叶洗澡还能驱除邪灵。神户市位于东京西南约 540 公里处，分为九个不同的区域，称为“区”。须磨区坐落于神户的海岸线上，是一个田园诗般的地方，拥有白色的沙滩、木栈道、咖啡馆，周围的山坡上还可以看到樱花树。然而，即使是美丽的风景也无法掩盖
the awful sight that was presenting itself on residential streets of the area in March 1997. Dead cats, some strangled and others mutilated, were found on the sidewalks. The horrified and distressed locals were at a loss to explain the attacks. On Sunday, March 16, 1997, 10-year-old Hayaka Yamashita left her home in Sumo Ward. Although she was by herself, the sight of the little girl walking amongst the crowd raised no concerns from passers-by. Known worldwide for being a safe country, it is common for young people to run errands in Japan without parental supervision. Korbe, the seventh largest city in Japan, is regarded as one of the safest. Unbeknownst
1997年3月，该地区住宅街道上呈现出的可怕景象。死猫被发现在人行道上，有的是被勒死的，有的是被肢解的。惊恐万状、痛苦不堪的当地居民对这些袭击事件百思不得其解。1997年3月16日星期日，10岁的山下彩花离开了位于须磨区的家。尽管她独自一人，但这个小女孩在人群中行走的身影并没有引起路人的任何担忧。日本作为世界上安全闻名的国家，年轻人没有父母监督而在国内跑腿是很常见的。神户作为日本第七大城市，被视为最安全的城市之一。然而彩花并不知道
to Hayaka, she was being watched by someone. As she emerged from the crowd and walked down a deserted street, the perpetrator saw his chance. Upon returning home afterwards, the perpetrator wrote the following entry in his diary. I carried out sacred experiments today to confirm how fragile human beings are. I brought the hammer down when the girl turned to face me. I think I hit her a few times, but I was too excited to remember. Hayaka Yamashita was found unconscious and taken to hospital. She succumbed to her injuries seven days later.
她正被某人监视着。当她从人群中走出来，走进一条荒凉的街道时，凶手看到了他的机会。事后回到家，凶手在日记中写下了以下内容。我今天进行了神圣的实验，以证实人类是多么脆弱。当女孩转身面对我时，我挥下了锤子。我想我打她了几下，但我太兴奋了，记不清了。山下彩花被发现时已经失去意识并被送往医院。七天后，她因伤势过重而身亡。
An investigation into Hayaka's death failed to unearth any suspects. Authorities suspected her killer was also responsible for stabbing a nine-year-old girl that day as well. Seriously wounded, but not fatally, the girl could not describe her attacker, only her immense surprise as an unknown male approached and drove a knife into her stomach. The community were appalled, as homicide in Kobe was nearly unheard of, let alone the murder of a child. Children's Day passed without celebration for Hayaka Yamashita's parents. Investigators were still no closer to catching her killer. They theorized that the murder may be related to a similar attack where a group of girls had been set upon by a male yielding a
对彩花死因的调查未能发现任何嫌疑人。当局怀疑她的凶手也是当天刺伤一名 9 岁女孩的幕后黑手。女孩受了重伤，但没有致命，她无法描述袭击者，只记得当一个陌生的男性接近并将一把刀刺入她的腹部时，她感到无比震惊。社区为之震惊，因为在神户凶杀案几乎闻所未闻，更不用说谋杀儿童了。山下彩花的父母在没有庆祝中度过了儿童节。调查人员距离抓获凶手仍无进展。他们推测，这起谋杀案可能与本月早些时候的一起类似袭击有关，当时一群女孩遭到了一名手持锤子的男子的袭击
hammer earlier that month, although with nowhere near the severity encountered by Hayaka. The group of girls did not recognize their attacker and could do little to shed blood on who he might be. Meanwhile, dead cats stopped appearing on the sidewalks. On Saturday, May 24, 1997, just over two months after the attack on Hayaka Yamashita, 11-year-old Jun Hase left his home in Kobe just before 6pm. Although intellectually impaired and only able to say his name, the exceedingly friendly and happy Jun was more than capable of making the 500-meter journey from his parents' house to his grandfather's house that night. Some of his friends were waiting at a nearby train station
尽管严重程度远不及彩花所遭遇的那样。这群女孩并不认识袭击者，也无法为究竟是谁提供任何线索。与此同时，死猫不再出现在人行道上。1997年5月24日星期六，就在袭击山下彩花两个多月后，11岁的长谷润在傍晚6点之前离开了他在神户的家。尽管长谷润智力受损，只能说出自己的名字，但这个极其友好和快乐的孩子完全有能力在当晚独自完成从父母家到祖父家500米的旅程。他的一些朋友正在附近的火车站等候
and called out to the popular Jun as he walked by. The perpetrator watched on. He approached Jun. Because of Jun's trusting nature, he was easily led into the hilly and deserted woodlands. When Jun failed to appear at his grandfather's house, his anxious family phoned the local police. After conducting a search of the local area, they failed to find any sign of the young boy. Suddenly, dead cats began appearing on the streets of Sumo Ward once more. Three days later, a janitor at the Kobe Municipal Tomigawa Oka Junior High School where Jun Hase attended as a student arrived for a day's work. At 6.40am, he approached the large iron front gate to the school and recoiled at the side in front of him.
并在受欢迎的长谷润走过时大声喊他。行凶者在一旁看着。他接近了长谷润。由于长谷润信任的本性，他轻易地被引诱进了丘陵起伏、荒无人烟的树林里。当长谷润没有出现在他祖父家时，他焦虑的家属打电话给当地警察。在对当地进行搜寻后，他们没有找到这个小男孩的任何踪迹。突然间，死猫再次开始出现在须磨区的街道上。三天后，长谷润作为学生就读的神户市立友生川冈初中的一名看门人来上班。早上6点40分，他走近学校巨大的铁艺前门，被眼前的景象吓得退缩了。
The decapitated head of Jun Hase was affixed to the gate. Jun's eyes had been gouged out and his mouth had been cut open from ear to ear. A piece of paper was wedged between Jun Hase's teeth. Retrieving the 10-centimeter piece of paper, police discovered a note written in red ink. Excerpts of the note taunted police reading, This is the beginning of the game. Try to stop me if you can, you stupid police. And, I desperately want to see people die. It is a thrill for me to commit murder. Nothing makes me more excited than killing. A bloody judgement is needed for my years of great bitterness.
长谷润被砍下的头颅被固定在大门上。长谷润的眼睛被挖出，嘴巴从耳边被割开。长谷润的牙齿之间塞着一张纸条。警察取回这块 10 厘米长的纸条，发现上面用红墨水写着一张便条。便条的节选嘲弄警察写道：这是游戏的开始。如果你能的话，尽量阻止我，你们这群愚蠢的警察。还有，我非常渴望看到人们死去。对我来说，杀人是一种刺激。没有什么比杀人更让我兴奋的了。为了我多年来的巨大痛苦，需要一个血腥的审判。
I have gone through with my long-held revenge. Catch me if you can. Also written on the note were two English words, school, misspelled as SH00LL and killer. The note was signed with the alias Sayito Sakakibara, a combination of six kanji symbols for the words sake, devil, rose, sacred, and fight. At the very bottom, written in black ink, was a symbol not used in the Japanese language. It consisted of a shape similar to a teardrop, above which was drawn a circle divided into four quarters. The act of sending the police a taunting message via a handwritten letter bore a striking resemblance
我已经完成了我蓄谋已久的复仇。有本事就抓住我吧。便条上还写着两个英文单词，school拼写错误为SH00LL，以及killer。便条是用化名酒鬼玫瑰十字（Sayito Sakakibara）签署的，这是代表“清酒”、“恶魔”、“玫瑰”、“神圣”和“战斗”这六个汉字的总和。最底部用黑墨水写着一个日本语言中没有使用的符号。它由一个类似于泪滴的形状组成，上方画着一个分成四个象限的圆圈。通过手写信件向警方发送嘲弄信息的行为惊人地相似
to another infamous crime spree, the Zodiac Killer. Having been active decades earlier, near 9000 kilometers away in California, Japanese authorities knew they weren't dealing with the Zodiac. But, a copycat. Schools in Kobe were closed while police scoured the area. The six kanji letters signed at the bottom of the note were found graffitied on outer walls of the school grounds, and two dead cats were found nearby. When searching a secluded woodland area approximately 500 meters from the school, the body of Jun Hase was found. An autopsy revealed that he had been strangled to death before being decapitated, and that the strangling took place soon after he had gone missing three
另一桩声名狼藉的犯罪狂潮，即“十二宫杀手”。几十年前，在9000公里外的加利福尼亚州活跃过，日本当局知道他们对付的不是十二宫，而是一个模仿者。神户的学校因警方搜查该地区而关闭。写在便条底部的六个汉字被发现涂鸦在学校操场的外墙上，附近还发现了两只死猫。在搜寻距离学校约500米的一个偏僻林地时，找到了长谷润的尸体。尸检显示，他在被斩首前被勒死，而且勒死发生在三天前失踪后不久。
days prior. Over 400 local police questioned nearly everyone in the middle-class neighborhood. They learned that in the week prior to Jun Hase's murder, a man aged in his 30s had been seen by a number of witnesses staring at the school from a parked car. The hunt began for the man who could only be described as wearing a navy jacket and glasses. Authorities believed that the killer of Jun Hase might have been a former pupil at the school. They theorized that he may have been inclined to carry out such an attack as retaliation for being mistreated or bullied during his school years. Detectives fervently checked school records of past pupils in the hope of identifying a person of interest. Nobody stood out. Meanwhile, anxiety swept the streets of Kobe, a city completely
400多名当地警察盘问了中产阶级社区的几乎所有人。他们了解到，在长谷润谋杀案发生前一周，多名目击者看到一名30多岁的男子坐在一辆停着的汽车里盯着学校。搜捕这个只能被描述为穿着海军蓝夹克和戴着眼镜的男子的行动开始了。当局认为长谷润的凶手可能是学校的前学生。他们推测他可能是因为在学校受到虐待或欺凌而怀恨在心，从而进行了这样的报复。侦探们热切地查阅了历届学生的学校档案，希望能找出相关人员。没有人脱颖而出。与此同时，焦虑席卷了神户的街道，这是一座对如此残忍的谋杀案完全陌生的城市。
unaccustomed to such a brutal murder. Parents accompanied their children to and from school and forbade them from going outdoors unsupervised. 250 extra police officers were dispatched to patrol the neighborhood. Japanese Prime Minister Ryutaro Hashimoto called for the killer to be found as soon as possible. Yet, he eluded police. Housewife Takako Miyoshi told The Washington Post, I feel resentment toward the police who have not been able to do anything. Two months have passed since one girl was stabbed and one killed, and as time passes, it becomes more difficult to solve the case. Although detectives were struggling to come up with a suspect, they did have some clues behind the method of his killing.
家长们陪同孩子上下学，并禁止他们无监督地外出。250名增援警察被派去巡逻该社区。日本首相桥本龙太郎呼吁尽快找到凶手。然而，他却避开了警察。家庭主妇三好贵子告诉《华盛顿报》：“我对什么都做不了的警察感到愤慨。一个女孩被刺伤，一个女孩被杀已经过去两个月了，随着时间的推移，破案变得更加困难。”尽管侦探们很难找到嫌疑人，但他们对他的杀人手法确实有一些线索。
Linguists and psychologists suggested that the killer may have been influenced by a television series that aired in Japan the year prior. In the popular thriller, the perpetrator stuffed a rose into the mouth of each of his victims as a calling card. Once again, the killing of cats in the neighborhood ceased. On June 6, 1997, two weeks after the murder of Jun Hase, a brown envelope arrived at the offices of newspaper Kobe Shinbun. It was postmarked June 3 and had no name or return address. The rambling 1400-word letter inside was signed by Sayito Sakakibara. The murder of Jun Hase had dominated news headlines since the young boy's death. In their haste to publish new details on the crime, including the note that had been shoved in Jun's mouth, the media had erroneously
语言学家和心理学家暗示，凶手可能受到了前一年在日本播出的电视剧的影响。在这部广受欢迎的惊悚片中，凶手在每个受害者的嘴里塞了一只玫瑰作为名片。社区里的猫再次停止了被杀戮。1997年6月6日，在长谷润谋杀案发生两周后，《神户新闻》社收到了一个棕色信封。它的邮戳是6月3日，没有姓名或回信地址。里面那封长达1400字的凌乱信件由酒鬼玫瑰十字（Sayito Sakakibara）签署。自从这个小男孩死后，长谷润的谋杀案一直占据着新闻头条。为了急于公布犯罪的新细节，包括塞进长谷润嘴里的便条，媒体错误地
mentioned that the note had been signed on Ibarra or Devil's Rose in English. This letter sought to clarify this mistake with Sayito Sakakibara writing, From now on, if you misread my name or spoil my mood, I will kill three vegetables a week. If you think I can kill only children, you are greatly mistaken. Detectives understood his use of the word vegetables as a disparaging term for people or for those with an intellectual or physical disability. The letter went on. If I was the same as I was when I was born, I probably would not have taken the trouble to place a severed head at the front gate of a junior high school. Anyone who tries can enjoy
提到该便条是用英文署名伊巴拉（Ibarra）或魔鬼玫瑰（Devil's Rose）的。这封信旨在澄清这个错误，酒鬼玫瑰十字（Sayito Sakakibara）写道：“从现在起，如果你读错我的名字或破坏我的心情，我一周将杀死三个蔬菜。如果你认为我只能杀死儿童，那就大错特错了。”侦探们明白他使用“蔬菜”一词是用来贬低人或智力或身体残疾者的贬义词。这封信继续写道。如果我和出生时一样，我可能不会大费周章地把一个断头放在初中正门。任何尝试的人都可以偷偷享受
killing people furtively. As one who has led and continues to lead an invisible existence, I have gone out of my way to attract public attention because I want to be recognised as a real person, at the very least in your fantasies. At the same time, I have not forgotten to take revenge on the compulsory education system which has created me as an invisible existence and the society which gave birth to this education system. However, I would gain nothing from mere revenge, save unburdening myself of the load of carried until now. So, I discussed this with a friend who, alone in the world, is invisible like myself. He said, for revenge that is worthy rather than miserable, mix your revenge with murder. Change
谋杀的乐趣。作为一个曾经并且继续过着隐形生活的人，我费尽心思引起公众的注意，因为我想被认为是一个真实的人，至少在你们的幻想中是这样。与此同时，也没有忘记向将我塑造成隐形存在的义务教育制度以及孕育了这个教育系统的社会复仇。然而，除了卸下至今背负的重担之外，单纯的复仇对我没有任何好处。于是，我和一个在世界上和我一样隐形的朋友商量了这件事。他说，为了不那么悲惨而有价值的复仇，把你的复仇和谋杀结合起来。改变
your hobby from murder to revenge and you will create a new world which is yours alone. Moved by those words, I have started this killing game. But even now, I don't know why I enjoy killing. I can only say that it is in my nature. It is only when I kill that I can be freed from daily hatred and feel a sense of relief. It is only other people's pain that can ease my pain. The arrival of this led off furthered the detective's belief that Sayito Sakakibara was influenced by the Zodiac Killer as he was well known for sending messages to authorities through newspapers. They speculated that the killing and mutilation of cats preempted each murder. Other than that, they had few leads to go on. The man in his 30s that they were chasing
你从谋杀到复仇的爱好，你将创造一个完全属于你自己的新世界。被这些话感动，我开始了这场杀人游戏。但即使到现在，我也不知道为什么我喜欢杀人。我只能说这是我的本性。只有在我杀戮的时候，我才能从日常的仇恨中解脱出来，感到一种解脱。只有别人的痛苦才能减轻我的痛苦。这封信的到来进一步增强了侦探们的信念，即酒鬼玫瑰十字（Sayito Sakakibara）受到了十二宫杀手的巨大影响，因为他以通过报纸向当局发送消息而闻名。他们推测，杀害和虐待猫是每次谋杀前的预演。除此之外，他们几乎没有什么线索可循。他们追捕的那个30多岁的男子
was not identified. On June 27, three weeks after the letter arrived at the newspaper Korbeshinbun, someone came forward with information to the police. They knew of a person who was particularly cruel to animals and who had confided that he had killed a cat for fun and buried it. The next day, the lead detective on the Jun Hase murder case held a televised press conference. After apprehending the male person for torturing cats, he confessed to the murder of Jun Hase, the bludgeoning murder of Ayaka Yamashita, the hammer attack on the group of girls, and the stabbing of the 9-year-old girl who survived the ordeal. He gave no motive to detectives other than saying, I simply wanted to try out various methods of killing.
身份尚未查明。6月27日，即这封信到达《神户新闻》三周后，有人向警方提供了线索。他们知道有一个人对动物特别残忍，并曾向人透露他为了好玩杀死了一只猫并把它埋了。第二天，长谷润谋杀案的首席侦探举行了一场电视新闻发布会。在逮捕了这名虐待猫的男子后，他承认了长谷润谋杀案、山下彩花的钝器谋杀案、对这群女孩的锤击案，以及刺伤9岁生还女孩的案件。他没有向侦探提供任何动机，只是说：“我只是想尝试各种杀人方法。”
He also admitted to being inspired to kill by comic book hero Baramon, who used beheading as one form of killing his enemies. The public were stunned as the detective announced they would not be releasing the name of the killer. This was because the perpetrator who had the entire city of Korbesh living in fear for over three months was not an adult. He was a 14-year-old school student. To protect the killer's identity, he was given the name Boye. Searching Boye's bedroom, detectives found a book about the 1990s New York Zodiac killer Copycat, violent comics, and horror movies, as well as his diary in which he documented his killings.
他还承认，他的杀戮灵感来自于漫画书英雄巴拉蒙（Baramon），该英雄将斩首作为杀死敌人的一种形式。当侦探宣布他们不会公布凶手的名字时，公众惊呆了。这是因为这个让整个神户市生活在恐惧中超过三个月的凶手不是成年人。他是一名14岁的初中生。为了保护凶手的身份，他被起了个代号叫“男孩A”（Boy A）。在搜查“男孩A”的卧室时，侦探们发现了一本关于20世纪90年代纽约十二宫杀手模仿犯的书、暴力漫画和恐怖电影，以及他记录自己杀戮的日记。
One week after the death of Ayaka Yamashita, he wrote, This morning my mom told me, poor girl, the girl that was attacked seems to have died. There is no sign of me being caught. He then went on to thank an imaginary god he named Barmoye Dorkishin for keeping him safe. Also taken into evidence was red tape identical to the tape used to seal the envelope sent to the newspaper and a knife which Boye admitted to using to behead Jun Hase along with a hacksaw. Neighbours were stunned by the arrest, telling the media that Boye came from a regular middle class working family. He could often be seen playing table tennis with his two younger brothers
在山下彩花死后的一周里，他写道：“今天早上我妈妈对我说，‘可怜的女孩，那个被袭击的女孩好像已经死了。’目前没有任何我被抓的迹象。”接着，他感谢了一个他取名为巴尔莫耶·多基辛（Barmoye Dorkishin）的虚构神明保护了他的安全。作为证据被带走的还有与用来密封寄往报纸的信封的胶带完全相同的红胶带，以及“男孩A”承认用来斩首长谷润的刀子和一个钢锯。邻居们对这次逮捕感到震惊，他们告诉媒体，“男孩A”来自一个普通的工薪阶层家庭。经常可以看到他与两个年幼的弟弟一起打乒乓球
or gardening with his family in their backyard. Boye's father worked for an established company and his mother did community work. He seemed to them like a normal and polite teenager. Classmates of Boye told a different story. At the Tomi Gaoka Junior High School where Boye was in the third grade, his classmates told of his love of cutting up frogs and torturing cats. Shortly before his attack on Jun Hase, he was expelled from school after bludgeoning a fellow student who bullied him with an iron pipe. According to his classmates, Boye would talk to Jun Hase in the playground. The discovery that these horrendous murders had been carried out
或者和家人在后院做园艺。男孩A的父亲在一家老牌公司工作，母亲则从事社区工作。在他们看来，他是一个正常而礼貌的青少年。男孩A的同班同学却讲述了一个不同的故事。在男孩A就读三年级的友生川冈初中，他的同学们讲述了他喜欢切青蛙和虐待猫的故事。就在他袭击长谷润之前，他因用铁管殴打一名欺负他的同学而被学校开除。据他的同学说，男孩A会在操场上与长谷润交谈。发现这些骇人听闻的谋杀案是由一个
by a 14-year-old with a hatred towards the education system caused despair amongst the Japanese population. Prime Minister Ryu Taro Hashimoto asked on television, where did we go wrong? Government officials and members of the public alike were quick to blame violence depicted in manga comics, video games and on film. The nation's construction minister said, movies lacking any literary or educational merit made for just showing cruel scenes can easily be watched by adolescent children. Adults should be blamed for this. In response, the education ministry announced a study into the relationship between violence in
对教育系统怀有仇恨的14岁少年犯下的，这在日本民众中引起了绝望。首相桥本龙太郎在电视上质问：“我们哪里做错了？”政府官员和公众很快将矛头指向了漫画、电子视频游戏和电影中描绘的暴力。日本建设大臣表示：“缺乏任何文学或教育价值、仅用于展示残酷场景的电影，很容易被未成年儿童观看。成年人应该对此负责。”作为回应，文部省宣布了一项关于暴力现象的研究
the media and its effect on young people. They also vowed to create a new curriculum in schools to focus on spiritual education and teaching the preciousness of life. Japan's education system also came under scrutiny for the pressure forced upon students without care given to their emotional well-being. Some speculated that the stress of intensive examinations became too much for the boy and he lashed out in violence. A mental health counselor in Korbe was reported in The Guardian as being particularly struck by Boy A's claim that he felt invisible in his letter to the newspaper. He said, his letter pinpoints a basic social problem. The Japanese are not good at communicating on an
媒体及其对年轻人的影响。他们还发誓要在学校创建一门新课程，重点是精神教育和教授生命的珍贵。日本的教育体系也因给学生施加压力而受到严厉审查，却没有照顾到他们的情感健康。一些人推测，高强度考试的压力对这个男孩来说太大了，他用暴力进行了反击。据《卫报》报道，神户的一位心理健康顾问对“男孩A”在给报纸的信中声称自己感到隐形一事尤为震惊。他说：“他的信指出了一个基本的社会问题。日本人不善于进行
individual basis. The boy wanted to communicate, he wanted to connect, but unfortunately he couldn't and his anger and feelings accumulated. Because of his age, Boy A served time in a medical reformatory for juveniles in western Tokyo to receive psychiatric treatment and counseling. Due to the seriousness of his crimes, in the year 2000, Japanese legislature was amended to lower the age of criminal responsibility from 16 to 14. On March 11, 2004, the Japanese Ministry of Justice announced that 21-year-old Boy A was being released on a provisional basis with full release to follow in January 2005. As reported in The Japan Times, the head of the parole board who decided on his release said,
个人层面的沟通。这个男孩想要沟通，他想要联系，但不幸的是他做不到，他的愤怒和情绪积聚了下来。由于他的年龄，男孩A在东京西部的少年医疗少管所服刑，接受精神病治疗和咨询。鉴于其犯罪情节严重，2000年，日本立法修正，将刑事责任年龄从16岁降至14岁。2004年3月11日，日本法务省宣布21岁的男孩A获准假释，并于2005年1月全面获释。据《日本时报》报道，决定将其释放的假释委员会负责人表示，
the board has interviewed the man on various occasions and closely examined his correctional state. We came to conclude that psychiatric care and correctional education at reformatries have obtained good results. Boy A's lawyer asked that his identity and whereabouts be protected, telling The Japan Times. If people around him make a big fuss and put him on the spot, it would make it difficult for him to reintegrate into society. By realizing the value of his own life, he now feels he wants to make up for having taken people's lives. He has grown up a lot in a short period of time. I am not worried about the possibility of repeated fancies. Boy A was released without incident and found work as a day laborer. His identity and whereabouts
委员会曾多次对该男子进行面谈，并对其矫正状态进行了仔细审查。我们得出的结论是，精神护理和少管所的矫正教育取得了良好的效果。男孩A的律师要求保护他的身份和下落，他告诉《日本时报》。“如果他身边的人大惊小怪并把他推到风口浪尖，这将使他难以重新融入社会。通过意识到自己生命的价值，他现在觉得自己想要弥补夺走人们生命的事实。他在短时间内成长了很多。我不担心重复幻想的可能性。”男孩A顺利获释，并找到了一份日工的工作。他的身份和下落
were protected. Through her lawyer, Boy A's mother released a statement to The Japan Times saying, Our son is now doing his best to have courage to plunge into the world of anxieties and uncertainties. I believe there will be a long and tough road ahead for us and our son. But, if possible, I hope the public will watch over us quietly. In June 2005, five months after his full release, Boy A published his memoir titled Zekka, under his pseudonym Sayito Sakakibara. Some bookstores refused to stock the memoir, but it quickly became a Japanese bestseller. The book's publisher defended its release, claiming that it gave an important insight into the mind of a killer.
得到了保护。通过他的律师，男孩A的母亲向《日本时报》发表了一份声明，称：“我们的儿子现在正尽最大努力鼓起勇气，陷入焦虑和不确定性的世界。我相信我们的儿子和我们将面临漫长而艰难的道路。但如果可能的话，我希望公众能默默地守护我们。”2005年6月，在他完全获释五个月后，男孩A以化名酒鬼玫瑰十字（Sayito Sakakibara）出版了他的回忆录《绝歌》（Zekka）。一些书店拒绝进货这本回忆录，但它很快成为了日本畅销书。该书的出版商为其发行进行了辩护，声称它为了解凶手的心理提供了重要的视角。
In the epilogue, Boy A writes, I couldn't keep quiet about my past anymore. I had to write, otherwise I thought I would go insane. Jun Haase's father vehemently opposed the release of the book. According to The Japan Times, Boy A sent him a copy with a handwritten letter of apology inside. Zekka detailed what had happened to Jun, including how Boy A had lured him into the woodlands to play before strangling and decapitating him and taking his head home in a plastic bag. According to his memoir, Boy A, who called himself an incorrigible sexual deviant, then took the head into the bathroom, locked the door, and committed an act far more heinous than murder.
在后记中，男孩A写道：“我再也无法对自己的过去保持沉默了。我必须写下来，否则我觉得我会发疯的。”长谷润的父亲强烈反对这本书的出版。据《日本时报》报道，男孩A给他寄了一本，里面附有一封手写的道歉信。《绝歌》详细记录了发生在长谷润身上的事情，包括男孩A是如何将他引诱到树林里玩耍，然后将其勒死并斩首，并把他的头颅用塑料袋带回家里的。根据他的回忆录，自称为不可救药的性变态的男孩A随后将头颅带进浴室，锁上门，犯下了比谋杀更令人发指的罪行。
As printed in The Japan Times, another excerpt of Zekka reads, When I advanced to junior high school, I had already become bored of killing cats, and gradually found myself fantasizing about how it would feel to murder human beings, like me. Although Boy A apologized to the families of his victims in the book, Jun Haase's father thought the apology shallow and false, saying, The book completely trampled on our feelings. It is clear that he is not sorry for what he did. According to The Star, the memoir also published the letters of apology that Boy A had sent to Ayaka Yamashita's mother every year since her death. Originally thinking that the letters were
正如《日本时报》所印发的，《绝歌》的另一个节选写道：“当我升入初中时，我已经厌倦了杀猫，渐渐发现自己开始幻想，像我这样谋杀人类会是什么感觉。”尽管男孩A在书中向受害者家属道歉，但长谷润的父亲认为这个道歉肤浅而虚伪，他说：“这本书彻底践踏了我们的感情。很明显，他对自己所做的事并不感到抱歉。”据《星报》报道，这本回忆录还公布了男孩A自山下彩花死后每年发给其母亲的道歉信。起初以为这些信件是
sincere, the printing of these in his memoir angered Ayaka's mother, who realized they were only written to be shared in his book. After the release of Zekka, some members of the public questioned whether Boy A was rehabilitated at all. Passages of text showed a man unrepentant for his actions. In one excerpt, he described his feelings after placing Jun Haase's head on the gate to the school, saying, Let me confess something. I thought the site was a beauty. I felt like I was born just to see the ethereal beauty of what was in front of my eyes. I thought I could die. In 2015, Boy A launched a website about himself titled The Unbearable Transparency of Being,
真诚的，这些内容在回忆录中的印刷激怒了彩花的母亲，她意识到这些信件只是为了在书中分享而写的。《绝歌》出版后，一些公众质疑男孩A是否得到了彻底的改造。文本段落显示了一个对自己的行为毫无悔意的男人。在一个节选中，他描述了将长谷润的头颅放在学校大门上的感受，说道：“让我坦白一件事。我觉得这个场景太美了。我觉得我生来就是为了看到眼前事物的空灵之美。我觉得我可以去死了。”2015年，男孩A建立了一个关于自己的网站，名为《存在的不可承受的透明度》（The Unbearable Transparency of Being），
in which he posted strange images of an unclothed man with black fabric covering his face. The man, whom Boy A claimed to be himself, was then photoshopped onto a variety of images. One was the torso of the naked man photoshopped onto the body of a scorpion. Another was of a naked man lying on his back, holding an alien slug-like creature with teeth between his legs. In retaliation for the launch of the website, which seemed only to serve Boy A's own vanity, Tabloid magazine The Shukan Post exposed Boy A's real identity. According to The Shukan Post, Boy A's real name is Shinichiro Azuma. In 2015, he lived in the Sayitama Prefecture, north of Tokyo. In 2021, it is unknown if he still lives
他在上面发布了一张奇怪的图片，画面是一个遮住脸的裸体黑布男子。男孩A声称这个男子就是他自己，然后被用Photoshop合成到各种图片中。其中一张是将裸体男子的躯干PS到蝎子的身体上。另一张是一个裸体男子仰卧着，两腿之间拿着一个带牙齿的外星蛞蝓状生物。为了报复该网站的推出，这似乎只为了满足男孩A的虚荣心，八卦杂志《周刊邮报》（The Shukan Post）曝光了男孩A的真实身份。据《周刊邮报》报道，男孩A的真名是东真一郎（Shinichiro Azuma）。2015年，他居住在东京以北的埼玉县。到了2021年，目前尚不清楚他是否仍居住在那里
there or if he has changed location. He is not required to report his whereabouts to any parole boards and is free to live his life with no restrictions. Boy A could be anywhere. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
或者他是否改变了地点。他不需要向任何假释委员会报告自己的行踪，并且可以毫无限制地自由生活。男孩A可能在任何地方。本集尚无评论。点击转录中的任意句子即可发表评论。